oh how does it feel to be the first to
stand on something and get shorter
hey real quick what kind of thug but
dazzle his skull
i'm loving the uh the weight adjustment
that you guys had to make with that
table because of check
shack and chuck that's a that's a pretty
fat ass
check and chuck that's what that is
right well uh
kevin i could see that uh you know
jumanji must ain't do that well you got
them a little ass diamonds on
you couldn't come out of this pandemic
with a better suit option
i'm so sick you were chucking these
awful suits y'all be wearing looking
like two beacons how do you have on
women's skinny jeans
i thought you think like a man hey
real quick i was just gonna say you got
way too many teeth on the bottom roll
your mouth and i'm just gonna tell you
i was gonna bet money that was over the
mountain she's supposed to oh wait his
crocodile got your teeth they attacked
him out there it is
okay he doesn't do it to me
he doesn't do it he has nothing to say
let me
finish you know and then he starts going
in his soliloquy and it doesn't matter
what he's saying
it was not you didn't have to say
solidify right there but it didn't fit
but why didn't you use it what is it
because that's how i talk about that's
how i talk
he wakes up and there's somebody that
gives them seven words he has to use
in that day
i read the dictionary every day i'm so
sick of you man
you dude let me tell you something you
don't you don't
commitments nothing out here a lot of
people here that i love tonight
we got a little pump we got little zan
uh these are also the reasons that your
12 year old cousin
wants a face tattoo stop writing on your
goddamn face
stop writing on your face it's stupid
you're not going to get a job
if this [ __ ] don't work out stop it
talking about he gonna take my job oh oh
take my job
what you know well all i gotta do is
point to myself and talk loud and say a
bunch of words
it doesn't make any sense that's all i
gotta do let me tell you something skip
okay i'm not going to talk about the
semantic
of this man and the submerity that he
does i'll send you a new
show where you sit in the hot tub your
body ain't that good
you can just walk around without your
shirt off if we're ever going to talk
about bodies i want you not to be the
one to bring that conversation up
all right if you don't get out of here
shaped like a beanbag that got that in
whose idea was it for the fake pregnancy
well i mean when you're having fake sex
then you have
fake babies yeah well you know what you
may have been having fake sex on your
side of the bed but on my side i was
tearing that
hey how come he didn't play in a
celebrity game this year man oh no
i'm in a hall of fame and celebrity
games it's over
it's over i can't do it anymore i
achieve greatness shaq you know what
that feels like
kenny i know you know what that feels
that's just adam stop it right there
uh we at dre's it's gonna be [ __ ]
amazing
uh duane get out my [ __ ] comment
section
go do something man you know what i got
something for your ass
i got something for your ass do it again
do it again and i'm gonna click on you
i'll click on you let the people see how
you look during the daytime
news flash dewayne's forehead isn't real
it's a prosthetic
dwayne rock johnson has a prosthetic
forehead
it's not real he can take it off it's
like velcro
if you see what's up under there you'll
see what wrestling to do to you
it's not good for your forehead
i'm on fire
there's a meeting coaching it's cool if
we just come sit in cool got it he
kevin hart uh currently i live
in los angeles i got a i got a house in
cabo
and uh another house in miami oh
god damn little island just brought a
little island
yeah that was cool you know me myself i
i like walks
long walks new york i got one in new
york
um philadelphia i got a place in philly
too
um jerk [ __ ] jersey i got one in jersey
too
this one goes to all the cold stars that
i've had except the rock because he
hasn't helped me
he hasn't helped me at all you've
actually
lessened my talent it's it's went down
since you've been in my life thank you
guys other than that man i'm just
i'm a regular dude i'm a regular dude
nice to meet you i'm just like yeah
yeah so just uh that's a little bit
about me
no different from anybody else in here
uh on my runway because i have a i have
an airplane runway
on my on my island that's where that's
where i walk at
i just go out there and walk sometime um
you know rihanna was kicked off
instagram for excessive nudity people
tell you something else she's so sexy
that i would honestly pay a million
dollars to see her naked here's the
thing i've already seen it and i'm
willing to pay again
i would i would still pay for it hey sir
what size is that
uh schmedium no no i'm talking about
your teeth what size of your teeth
look like you got a bunch of timberlands
in your mouth come on let's go man
thank god too late scott i'm thinking
too late
kev how are you doing i am good you're a
married man
i know off the market calm down ladies
it's all gone ladies you missed a chance
you missed your chance
i had a chance you chose 50 cent
you chose wrong she chose wrong back
then
you're a bully with a capital b
you come here and you bully people with
words that we don't understand half that
stuff ain't even in a dictionary excuse
me
that would be him you got to that would
be him that would be him that's not me
i've got nothing on him you're looking
at a player that's colossus
what did you say that would be funny he
liked him he colosticizes
in and that makes him a traumatic
disaster occasion what
kevin do you want to just hold on a
second there we go i just want to make
sure that you don't fall back and hit
your soft spot man if you don't get your
hand off my [ __ ] head
i hear a man of short stature that does
not mean i'm a
baby hey huh huh huh
how many kids on that hey just tell me
how many keys
let me see it man we got
you know what i'm saying just little
bitty baby
here's the number one rule in hollywood
don't work with no [ __ ] animals
don't work with no [ __ ] kids i agree
i did are we there yet
and they're 10 times more professional
than this one you got you know what
you've got another thing coming i don't
know if we could do that
thanks so much for being here guys did
you see shaq you got a chance you saw
his big behind in the back what is shaq
doing
since his retirement he he has nothing
to do he's in the most random places
well thank you
thank you very much yeah yeah i'm
serious i saw him like home depot
two weeks ago just but yeah he was
helping people like he wasn't even
shopping he was just helping people
put stuff in the car i'm shocked i don't
have nothing to do you want me to grab
it i'll help you
like you have to understand like i'm 6'1
i'm not sure no no i'm i'm just small
like look here's here's the bad part
with me like if i sit all the way back
[Music]
[Music]
only my face is black only my lips is
black your whole body black like man
because i'm dark skinned
that's why you can't get no work listen
you're too dark i'm working for the
blackened catfish
i bet this i bet we'll all be able to
tell jamie real eight if he stop
coloring his hair
i know i got more talent in my season
than you
how about that you should rub up against
this hairline and get a movie
hey you know what how about i let you
borrow some of this why not maybe
somebody might
you want to get an autograph from your
mate
while i drive out why don't you sit down
why don't you sit on the front of my car
you hood ornament now you can't say get
a movie because you know i'm [ __ ]
working down we're where you working at
i'm working jimmy i'm doing a movie
right now too i'm feeling right now i'm
constantly [ __ ] okay
i bet they won't hire jamie the more if
they figure out where his hairline
really starts
let's all bet mine right now